from really trying to get good semantics
functors when we want to give some funk
toriel semantics to these these diagrams
of network systems
so what Don introduced decorated
correlations to construct sorry
so curse perhaps thank you to construct
this category I want to extend this
framework and generalize it to decorated
correlations and in particular the the
message are we doing we had it's working
on here is this synced to some yeah
switch the slides switching the slides
on here but not on on the main spirit
okay I think
okay now let's start again so the
message I want you get after that pause
is that all a decorator cut all
hypergraph categories decorated
correlation categories so in the context
of this conference we saw David
yesterday introduce hypergraph
categories among among other structures
that come from our prides of wiring
diagrams and in particular gave examples
like the category of matrices or arrays
and also relations and maybe linear
relations John this morning introduced
decorated cross bands and so what I want
to do is sort of combine these two
things then next Dan will give some what
a talk somewhat dual to this talking
about constructing hypergraph categories
with the relations and then we might see
applications of this sort of stuff later
on
save by Ross's talk so let me remind you
first what a hypergraph category is and
the slogan we want is the hypergraph
categories model network
compositionality the picture we want is
simply a morphisms in this category
hypergraphs
so slightly more formally let me say
that a hypergraph category is a
symmetric 1:02 category in which each
object is clipped with a special
commutative Frobenius monitor in a way
coherent with the monoidal product so
what does this mean well as a category
we have these objects and as monado
category you can put them side-by-side
if you have two collections collections
of objects we have put more officers I
mean in a symmetric modal category given
two morphisms we can compose them by
sort of moving things along and
connecting wires up maybe switching
maybe permuting a little bit in a
hypergraph category were allowed this
much more free notion of composition
where we're allowed to split wires
terminate wires bend wires around and
connect sort of arbitrary or as many
wires as we like together so this is
sort of wiring structure is afforded by
the special commuter to frobenius monoid
on each object
the current property is is essentially
that if we have X and we have a
modification or the Frobenius structure
on X and we have Y and therefore being
in structure and Y then we can get the
Frobenius structure on x times y by by
pairing them together and so the the
morphism is there's no coherence with
respect to the morphisms which is
interesting
perhaps the source of concern but moving
on so now it seems customary to give a
montage of of network diagrams but I'll
skip past that and recall that like John
in in trying to formalize these things
and formalizing these things and getting
these steps was a good general theory
formalized these as as decorated cursed
fan categories and my claim in the
previous slides is that these things
should be formalized as hypergraph
categories so we would hope then since
generally I like to agree that all these
decorative cosine categories are are in
fact hypergraph categories and that's
true so so decorated cursed bands build
hypergraph categories in fact this this
is due to sort of structure on the
categories or curse bags themselves so
if we recall the setting is a category C
with finite cur limits and we construct
this category cursed fancy where the
morphisms look like this that
corresponds so every Co spam category is
a hypergraph category with the monoidal
product and you john already went
through the fact that they they form a
symmetric modal category with this with
this monoidal product more interestingly
now the the Frobenius maps are given by
the the cur diagonal map and the initial
at nav on each object so by properties
of the co product we always get a map
from the core product of an object X
with itself to 2 X and so we can we can
get this this Frobenius multiplication
by using the the co diagonal map
the the comarca patient by taking the
opposite nap and similarly the unum the
career not given by the initial map and
its opposite and this allows this more
sort of hypergraph notion of wiring
diagrams so when you have you decorate a
cosine category we get a notion of empty
or undecorated crisp an and and in fact
this gives an embedding of the category
of curse bands just a and C into the
category of decorator curse bands and we
can see the sort of hyper graph
structure inherited along this embedding
right so decorator chrisbehrens build
hyper graph categories and this is great
especially syntactically so if you
recall he has a decorator coastline
category if we haven't decorated a coast
band if you have another decorator coast
and we can six them together we can
compose them we can take from local
products but if you notice the the
decoration in the in the sense that of
grows and grows and grows and eventually
we put together we've diagrams like this
which is great because we want to be
able to describe these diagrams but but
we don't want all our categories to be
so free in particular we might want
semantic situations where where we start
identifying different diagrams so let me
give you an example if you consider this
pair of decorator cross bands or open
circuits they're just just to open one
ohm resistors then their composite is as
this decorated coast band is is to 1 ohm
resistors in parallel in series in some
sense this is equivalent to a 2 ohm
resistor and the sense that that
equivalent is this if we if we get these
circuits and put them each in a black
box such that we're only allowed to
probe the terminals by measuring
electrical behavior on either side so so
and send potentials at these two points
then we could not tell these two
circuits apart no you're exactly the
same measurements and so we want to
construct a semantic category in which
these two two morphisms are essentially
the same thing that this thing composes
to this thing and to do this we need to
use decorator correlations so the key
idea is that we only we can't see this
center node here we sort of don't even
know it exists and so we only want to
decorate really the the boundary of this
of this coast band so the stuff that
lives can be said to live here and here
so let's let's see how that goes in
practice first if this is just the pair
of decorated coast bands at the top of
the previous slide I've just put them
down there and so let me remind you how
we compose these as decorator Chris
bands first we take the push out over Y
and then we transfer the decoration up
across across this map from from the the
co-product
all those sort of disjoint sum of these
two things onto the the new I pecs
and we arrived with okay and so so this
thing here is our composite decorator
Chris BAM
in in this case to move to decorator
correlations it sort of pays to run with
this behavioral extensional idea that I
was I was talking about earlier so
instead of decorating these coast bands
in this example with circuit diagrams
we're going to decorate them with
measurements of with it with the sets of
possible behaviors or observations so
these are these are subsets of the space
of potentials in the space occurrence at
these nodes in fact linear subspaces and
how you read one of these things is that
this 1 ohm resistor corresponds to to
this space here with this X being the
potential over here this Y being the
protector over here and then then we
have a constraint right coming from
Ohm's law which says that this this 1
ohm thing here has the constant of
proportionality between the potential
difference in the current along this
edge so the current in that X will be X
minus y and the current in at Y will be
the negative Y minus X
so so this gives this is another way of
describing these 2 1 ohm resistors as a
decorated as two decorated coast bands
now composing these again we have a
coherent way of pushing these
decorations up onto this this new apex
and the way is by identifying potential
so the potential here which overridden Y
is equal to the potential here which
I've written Y Prime and so it's just Y
over here but then we add the currents
so so here this is now 2y minus X plus
there okay so that that gives us the
composite decorator coast band but for a
decorator correlation again we only care
about what happens at the image of of
the new boundary so we're going to
factor our map into into a surjection or
an FP morphism onto the image and then a
mono morphism or injection on into the
the cur domain and then we have a
coherent way of transferring our
decoration up onto this this new apex
where we've said that while the
potential here can be anything we like
so we'll just forget that wire but we're
going to we don't want current leaking
out in the center of our black box so
we're going to force this to be 0 so
then 2 y equals x plus said and if we do
some algebra we get we get this subspace
up here as our a new decoration
now one observation you make so this is
a new decorator correlation and one
observation you can make is that the
cost of proportionality between the
current and the potential difference is
now 2 so this is sort of corresponds in
this picture to a 2 ohm resistor
right so so let's recap that quickly
what happened was we we had this
decoration coming from our two decorator
Chris pans we pushed it on - we
transferred it up onto the push out and
then we transferred again backwards
along this injection onto the image of
our boundary so to introduce some
notation for that we rewrite our crisp
and composite coast and like this as F
and what we did was we factored it
factored it into an injection in a
surjection
and then we transfer the decoration
along this this map here - so to
construct our category of decorated
correlations we need a notion of
constructing of transferring decorations
along forwards along the map and C and
backwards along a map in M
to arrive at these factorizations we
need in general what's called a Coast
table factorization system and and here
is so in this example C was the category
of finite sets and then this
factorization system was the surjection
interaction factorization system so more
generally we write yes for the category
with morphisms a morphism and c then a
backwards morphism in m and now to
construct decorated coast bands we used
a functor from from c2 to set because
all we're interested in doing was
pushing decorations along along that
sand sea but now we we have this
slightly more general category here and
a functor from c composed em off and and
the main theorem then is this in exactly
the same way we now get a high pat wall
we always got a hypergraph category but
in particular we gotta have graph
category of decorated correlations here
with the objects are the objects to see
and the morphisms are decorated curse
bands subject to the constraint that
these curse bands are what we saw as
during the epoch on to the image so this
is in the second example this was a
joint surjection but more generally it's
jointly lying in in the first half of
our factorization system
right so 4 factorial semantics is
important we also get a hyper graph
functor and in the same sort of way as
decorate it as we did for decorated
coast bands given more these more
general functors and a natural
transformation between them we can also
get a hyper graph um to giving semantics
from that between between say a
syntactic category which could just be
coast bands if we use a trivial
factorization system to something like
our linear relations built as a hyper
graph built as a decorated correlation
category and then the main theorem I I
want to present today is that every
hyper graph category is equivalent as a
hyper graph category to something
constructed in this way
in fact we we get an equivalence of
categories once we allow for for a
notion of change of base right so we can
change out a category see where these
coast bands live event our factorization
system and we get a category of
decorated correlations category cushion
act decorated correlation categories I
mean this is equivalent to the category
of hypergraph categories so to recap the
first claim was that we should we can
use hypergraph categories whenever we
want to model is this sort of notion of
composition and then we saw that
decorator chris bans give hypergraph
categories but into the free or initial
way and so to to get at more across the
notions of semantics like this black box
idea we can use decorator for
correlations but then the theorem is
that that this solution is is general
and whenever we want to construct a
hyper graph category we can use the soda
technique
[Applause]
I know what a authorization system isn't
so what this means is that the the Class
M was was stable and is stable under
push outs what this means again that's
given to say we have an app in M and
then another mapping and C and if we
take this this push out diagram we get
this map here will also be an M that's
that's important for both composing
correlations by taking push outs and
factorizations and making sure you still
have a correlation as well as making
sure the decorations transfer nicely
they've been can you comment on the
relationship between hypergraph
categories